YOU’RE GOING TO LOOK FANTASTIC.
LAWRENCE: THANK YOU, MY FRIEND.
>> LAWRENCE YOU ARE IN TEXAS
RIGHT NOW, RIGHT?
LAWRENCE: THAT’S RIGHT.
>> WITH THAT WE’VE GOTTA BRING
IN TEXAS CONGRESSMAN DAN
CRENSHAW TO HELP US OUT WITH
NEWS OF THE DAY.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU, CONGRESSMAN
THERE’S SO MUCH GOING ON RIGHT
NOW WITH COVID, SHORTAGE OF
TESTING, SHORTAGE OF MONOCLONAL
ANTIBODIES THAT I DON’T THINK IS
GETTING ENOUGH ATTENTION, AND
FOR THE VERY FIRST TIME EVER,
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS SORT OF
WASHING HIS HANDS OF THIS SAYING
THAT THERE IS NO SUCH THING AS A
FEDERAL SOLUTION TO ALL OF THIS.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE CURRENT
STATE OF THINGS WHEN IT COMES TO
COVID AND PRESIDENT BIDEN’S
RECENT REMARKS?
>> YEAH, IT’S LIKE HE GETS IT
BACKWARDS.
THERE IS A FEDERAL RESPONSE TO
COVID.
IT’S JUST NOT WHAT HE’S DOING SO
WHAT HE’S DOING IS IMPOSING
UNCONSTITUTIONAL MANDATES, THE
OSHA MANDATES THAT WOULD
REQUIRE BUSINESSES TO FIRE
WORKERS WHO AREN’T VACCINATED.
THAT’S THE OPPOSITE OF WHAT HE
SHOULD BE DOING.
WHAT HE SHOULD BE DOING IS
AIDING OUR SUPPLY SYSTEMS AND
AIDING OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEMS SO
HOW DO YOU DO THAT?
WELL PRESIDENT TRUMP DID IT BY
ENGAGING IN OPERATION WARP SPEED
, BY CREATING A TESTING
REGIME THAT WAS REALLY SECOND TO
NONE BY THE TIME IT WAS UP AND
GOING, ALL BIDEN HAD TO DO WAS
CONTINUE TO DO THOSE THINGS,
CONTINUE IMPROVING UPON THOSE
THINGS, AND HE SORT OF
WASHED HIS HANDS OF IT AND
INSTEAD TRIED TO TAKE THIS
HAMMER TO THE SITUATION
INSTEAD OF THE  SCALPAL THAT’S
BEEN NEEDED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO ACTUALLY GET
THINGS GOING.
IN TEXAS WE ARE ONE OF THE
STATES THAT DOESN’T HAVE
THESE MONOCLONAL ANTIBODIES ANY
MORE, WE’VE RUN OUT AND
COMPLAINING TO THE
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT HOW THESE
FORMULAS ARE DISTRIBUTED NOT
JUST BEFORE MONOCLONAL
ANTIBODIES BUT ALSO FOR VACCINE
DISTRIBUTION AS WELL SO THIS
ADMINISTRATION JUST HASN’T
HAD THE ORGANIZATIONAL WHERE
WITH ALL TO REALLY DEAL WITH
THIS AND THEY’RE LEARNING THE
HARD WAY THAT THEY PROBABLY
OWE THE TRUMP ADMINITRATION AN
APOLOGY BECAUSE AS I RECALL
EVERYBODY CALLED TRUMP A
MURDERER JUST BECAUSE THERE WAS
A GLOBAL PANDEMIC COMING THROUGH
AND THE FIRST TIME WE DEALT WITH
IT.
>> YEAH IT’S AMAZING JUST HOW
THINGS CAN CHANGE SO QUICKLY.
YOU KNOW, YOU’RE IN CONGRESS,
YOU’RE SITTING THERE, YOU’RE A
TEXAN BUT YOU’RE IN D.C.
IT’S PROBABLY HARD, A LITTLE BIT
, TO SEE THIS HAPPENING TO
THE PEOPLE YOU CARE ABOUT AND
REPRESENT, TO NOT BE ABLE TO GO
GET A TEST OR  TO JUST HAVE AN
ADMINISTRATION SEEM LAZY
ON-THE-JOB.
WHAT CAN CONGRESS DO, WHAT CAN
YOU DO AS THEIR CONGRESSMAN NOW
AND I DON’T MEAN TO POINT IT
DIRECTLY AT YOU BUT WHAT CAN
CONGRESS DO TO HELP YOUR
CONSTITUTENTS TO MAYBE GET TESTS
OR  FEEL BETTER ABOUT THIS?
>> WELL, WE’D LOVE TO BE ABLE
TO GIVE YOU BETTER NEWS BUT THE
REALITY IS CONGRESS HAS
ALREADY APPROPRIATED TENS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO THIS
SPECIFIC PROBLEM, RIGHT NOW
IT’S A MANAGEMENT PROBLEM.
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH IS NOT
EXECUTING THESE DOLLARS IN AN
EFFICIENT MANNER.
THAT’S WHAT’S GOING ON, AND
AGAIN, LOOK.
I’M A CONSERVATIVE.
I ALWAYS MAKE SURE PEOPLE KNOW,
THERE IS ONLY SO MUCH GOVERNMENT
CAN DO, AND THE MOMENT THAT IT
STARTS DOING MORE THAN IT SHOULD
BE DOING, YOU START TO SEE UN
INTENDED SECOND AND THIRD
ORDER CONSEQUENCES THAT
EVERYBODY IS WORSE THAN YOU
WANTED TO SO WHAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SHOULD BE DOING AGAIN
, USING THEIR FEMA
RESOURCES TO BOLSTER A LOT OF
THESE TESTING SITES OPEN UP NEW
TESTING SITES THIS IS WHAT WE
SAW HAPPEN DURING THE TRUMP
ADMINITRATION.
THEY SHOULD BE USING OUR
RESOURCES TO INCREASE THOSE
SUPPLY CHAINS TO GET THOSE
MONOCLONAL ANTIBODIES
OUT TO PEOPLE FASTER, AND
PRESIDENT BIDEN ANNOUNCED THIS ,
WE JUST HAVEN’T SEEN RESULTS
FROM IT, HELPING US GET MORE
HEALTHCARE WORKERS FROM THE
MILITARY OR  FROM FEMA, TO
AID IN SOME OF THESE HOSPITALS
THAT ARE FEELING A LITTLE BIT
OVERWHELMED.
STILL WORTH NOTING THAT AT OUR
HEIGHT OF HOSPITALIZATIONS RIGHT
NOW, IT REALLY DOESN’T EVEN
COMPARE TO THE HEIGHT THAT WE
HAD BEFORE IN 2020, SO I DON’T
WANT PEOPLE TO PANIC ABOUT THIS
, BUT LOOK, TAKE THE SAME
PRECAUTIONS YOU’VE BEEN TAKING
FOR TWO YEARS.
LAWRENCE: I THINK YOU’RE RIGHT,
CONGRESSMAN, WE’VE GOTTA LIVE
WITH THIS AND LEARN HOW TO
PROTECT THE VULNERABLE, AND IF
WE DO THAT, I THINK WE’RE GOING
TO BE JUST FINE.
I WANT TO SHIFT TO SOME FOREIGN
POLICY NEWS.
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS EXPECTED TO
SPEAK WITH RUSSIAN LEADER
VLADIMIR PUTIN AHEAD OF THE
GENEVA TALKS, SO WHAT SHOULD
THE PRESIDENT PROJECT TODAY?
IT SEEMS LIKE AFTER THAT LAST
CHAT THAT HE HAD, PUTIN REALLY
DIDN’T GET THE MESSAGE.
HE SENT MORE TROOPS SO WHAT DOES
HE NEED TO DO TODAY TO PROJECT
STRENGTH?
>> SO PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS TO
MAKE CLEAR THAT THERE WILL BE
COSTS AND CONSEQUENCES TO
WHATEVER PUTIN DOES WITH THE
UKRAINE.
NOW I THINK EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT
WE’RE NOT REALLY WILLING TO SEND
TROOPS TO THE UKRAINE AND FIGHT
THE RUSSIANS AND EASTERN EUROPE
FOR THIS , AND THERE’S A LOT OF
PEOPLE ON OUR SIDE, A LOT OF
PEOPLE SAYING THAT THESE WAR MON
GERS HAD ARE JUST TRYING
TO GET US INTO WAR.
WELL JUST HOLDUP A LITTLE BIT.
THERE’S A LOT OF OPTIONS IN
BETWEEN DOING NOTHING AND IN
BETWEEN WAR.
LOTS OF OPTIONS OUT THERE.
MOSTLY ECONOMIC SANCTIONS, BUT
THAT’S WHAT PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS
BEEN TALKING ABOUT.
IT SEEMS HE NEEDS TO BE A BIT
MORE SPECIFIC AND MAYBE HIT
PUTIN A LITTLE BIT MORE PERSONAL
LY WITH HIS OWN FINANCES
, IF THERE’S GOING TO
ACTUALLY SUCCESSFULLY DETER THE
UKRAINE.
I THINK TAKING A PAGE OUT OF THE
TRUMP PLAY BOOK WOULD
ACTUALLY WORK QUITE WELL HERE.
WHAT TRUMP DID WHICH WAS
DIFFERENT THAN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION WAS ACTUALLY GIVE
THE UKRAINIANS DEFENSE WEAPONS
AS OPPOSE TO SAY LOGISTICAL
SUPPLIES AND THAT KIND OF AID.
THAT SENDS A PRETTY CLEAR
MESSAGE TO THE RUSSIANS THAT
THIS FIGHT WILL NOT BE AS EASY
AS YOU WANT IT TO BE.
DOESN’T MEAN AMERICA IS GOING TO
COME IN GUN SLINGING GOING TO
WAR.
THAT’S NOT WHAT THIS MEANS AT
ALL.
WHAT IT DOES MEAN IS THERE WILL
BE SOME MINIMAL AMOUNT OF
SUPPORT THAT MAKES THE COSTS TOO
HIGH FOR YOU TO DO THIS.
>> ONE OF THE MORE CONCERNING
HEADLINES AFFECTS YOUR HOME
STATE OF TEXAS.
IN HARRIS COUNTY, 113 PEOPLE
CHARGED WITH CAPITOL MURDER, SO
THE MOST SERIOUS CRIME THERE IS,
THEY WERE GRANTED BOND, RELEASED
BACK INTO THE COMMUNITY, AND
SOME OF THEM RE-OFFENDED.
WHEN YOU’RE TALKING ABOUT 113
PEOPLE, THIS ISN’T JUST A ONE-
OFF.
THIS SEEMS TO BE THE SYSTEM
THAT’S IN PLACE.
WHAT NEEDS TO CHANGE HERE,
CONGRESSMAN?
>> THIS IS SOME GREAT LOCAL
REPORTING DONE IN MY HOMETOWN,
WHICH SHOWED US WHAT WE ALREADY
KNEW, THAT A LOT OF THE CRIME
BEING COMMITTED IS BEING
COMMITTED BY THE SAME EXACT
PEOPLE OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
THEY JUST KEEP GETTING RELEASED
OUT ON BAIL.
NOW, FOR VIOLENT OFFENDERS YOU
REALLY GOTTA SCRATCH YOUR HEAD
AND WONDER HOW THAT’S POSSIBLE.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE BEING
CHARGED WITH CAPITOL MURDER AND
THEN RELEASED ON BOND, NO
PROBLEM, LEFT OUT INTO THE
STREETS, AND BIG SURPRISE
THEY ACTUALLY COMMITTED ANOTHER
MURDER AND KILLED AGAIN.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO SHOULD BE
ALIVE RIGHT NOW, WERE IT NOT FOR
THESE LIBERAL JUDGES WHO
THEY OPERATE OFF OF THIS FALSE
SENSE OF COMPASSION.
THEY THINK THEY ARE DOING THE
WORLD A KINDNESS OF SOME
SORTS BY LETTING THESE CRIMINALS
GET OUT BUT IN THE END THEY ARE
DOING THE OPPOSITE.
THEY GO OUT AND THEY HURT PEOPLE
, THEY HARM PEOPLE, THESE
ARE VIOLENT PEOPLE AND A REASON
WE HAVE A SYSTEM THE WAY WE HAVE
IT.
THIS IS HAPPENING NOT JUST IN
HOUSTON, OF COURSE.
THIS IS THE STORY ACROSS ALL
MAJOR AMERICAN CITIES WHERE
YOU’RE SEEING MURDERS SPIKE.
THE BAIL REFORM, THE FALSE
COMPASSION OF DA’S AND
PROSECUTORS FUNDED BY GEORGE SOR
OS TO BE IN THOSE
POSITIONS THAT IS THE
STORY OF CRIME ACROSS
AMERICA RIGHT NOW.
THE GOOD NEWS IS FOR AMERICA WE
CAN VOTE THEM OUT.
DA’S, JUDGES, IN TEXAS WE VOTE
FOR JUDGES WE CAN VOTE THEM OUT,
AND GET OUR STREETS BACK.
>> YOU TALK ABOUT VOTING THEM
OUT.
I KNOW THAT TEXAS, I LIVE IN
TEXAS FOR A LITTLE WHILE FOR A
COUPLE YEARS AND I THINK I’M 18
YEARS FROM BEING ABLE TO CALL
MYSELF A TEXAN, I WAS TOLD IT
HAD TO BE 20 YEARS TO CLAIM THE
TITLE BUT I WAS AROUND A LOT
OF PEOPLE MOVING IN FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA, THE TECH
INDUSTRY WAS THERE, AND I KNOW
TEXAS, LIKE WHERE I’M AT IN
GEORGIA, THE BALANCE OF POWER IS
KIND OF EVENING OUT AND 50/50,
IS THIS A PART OF THAT?
IS THAT WHY WE’RE SEEING STUFF
LIKE THIS HAPPEN IN TEXAS OR  IS
THIS A ONE OFF THING HAPPENING
HERE AND I THINK IT’S HARRIS
COUNTY.
>> WELL, SOME WHAT CORRECT.
I WOULDN’T COMPARE IT TO GEORGIA
JUST YET.
I THINK IT’S STILL A LOT REDDER
THAN GEORGIA HAS BECOME, BUT IT
IS THE STORY OF THE URBAN-RURAL
DIVIDE, WHERE IN URBAN AREAS IT
GETS BLUER AND BLUER AND BLUER,
AND THE RURAL AREAS JUST GET RED
DER AND REDDER AND SO
IT’S TOUGHER AND TOUGHER IN
THESE BLUE AREAS.
HOUSTON, UNTIL RECENTLY, WAS RUN
BY A REPUBLICAN COUNTY JUDGE.
HARRIS COUNTY WAS A REPUBLICAN
COUNTY JUDGE, BUT THAT CHANGED
RECENTLY AND LOOK AT THE OUTCOME
S THAT WE GET BECAUSE OF
THAT SO I THINK PEOPLE ARE ABLE
TO SEE PAST THEIR SORT OF JERSEY
-WEARING HERE, THE RED AND
THE BLUE AND JUST VOTING FOR
YOUR TEAM, AND SEE THE
CONSEQUENCES OF POLICY
ACTIONS, AND I HOPE THAT REMAINS
THE CASE.
LAWRENCE: YEAH, YOU’RE RIGHT,
CONGRESSMAN, BECAUSE IT’S
SOMETHING SIMILAR IN DALLAS AS
WELL.
YOU KNOW, DALLAS IS RUN BY A LOT
OF THE PROGRESSIVES BUT THE
SUBURBS OUTSIDE OF DALLAS,
WITHIN THE COUNTY, THEY’RE MORE
RED, SO PART OF YOUR EFFORT IS
TO KEEP TEXAS RED AND THAT’S A
BIG ISSUE IN OUR STATE, SO YOU
GOT EXCLUSIVE FOR FOX & FRIENDS.
YOU’RE GOING TO IN VAIL TEXAS
RELOADED IN AN EFFORT TO KEEP
TEXAS RED.
WE’VE GOT A LITTLE CLIP OF IT
AND THEN WE’LL HAVE YOU REACT,
CONGRESSMAN, WATCH.
>> ALL RIGHT >> YEAH, I’M
GONNA NEED ANOTHER TEAM.
>> [LAUGHTER]
LAWRENCE: SO CONGRESSMAN, YOU’VE
GOT YOURSELF IN THERE, OBVIOUSLY
WESLEY HUNT, A VETERAN
AS WELL AS MORGAN LUTRELL, ALSO
ANOTHER VETERAN.
>> THAT’S RIGHT AND JUST A
LITTLE TEASER FOR YOU.
WE’RE STILL WORKING ON THE REST
OF THE MOVIE IT’S GOING TO BE
REALLY COOL AND YOU CAN SUPPORT
OUR EFFORTS TO DO THAT, BY THE
WAY AT TEXAS RELOADED.COM.
THAT’S WHERE PEOPLE CAN GO AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE GET THIS
REALLY COOL AD UP ON TV
AND GET THESE TWO GUYS ELECTED
SO THEY’RE BOTH RUNNING RIGHT IN
THE HOUSTON AREA, FOR TEXAS 38
AND TEXAS 8, GREAT GUYS,
VETERANS, WESLEY HUNT IS A
FORMER APACHE PILOT AND MORGAN
LUTRELL IS A SEAL FOR 14
YEARS HAND PICKED BY RICK PERRY
TO WORK UNDER THE TRUMP
ADMINITRATION FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF ENERGY, VERY SMART GUY, SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER, AND YOU CAN’T
IMAGINE BETTER CANDIDATES FOR
CONGRESS RIGHT NOW, AND OUR
ELECTIONS ARE COMING UP THAT’S
WHY WE’RE DOING THIS VIDEO
BECAUSE OUR PRIMARY ELECTIONS
ARE COMING UP IN EARLY MARCH AND
SO WANT TO GET THESE TWO OVER
THE FINISH LINE AND YOU CAN
SUPPORT THEM AT TEXASRELOADED
.COM.
>> WELL, CONGRESSMAN I STILL
REMEMBER THE FIRST ONE THAT YOU
DID IN 2020 AND IT HAD AN
AIRPLANE, EXPLOSIONS, THE
WHOLE THING SO IT REALLY IS
A GOOD IDEA BECAUSE IT STICKS IN
PEOPLE’S MEMORIES.
WHAT IS IT LIKE FILMING AN  AD
LIKE THIS AND WHOSE IDEA
WAS THIS?
>> IT’S MY IDEA.
>> [LAUGHTER]
>> THESE ARE GENERALLY MY IDEAS
LAWRENCE: ALWAYS.
>> I’LL ADMIT, MY IDEA.
I LIKE DOING THIS SORT OF
CREATIVE DIRECTION KIND OF THING
, IF YOU FOLLOW ME YOU
PROBABLY GET A SENSE FOR THAT OF
COURSE ALREADY AND WHAT’S IT
LIKE?
WE BRING IN A REALLY
PROFESSIONAL CREW TO DO THIS SO
IT DOES FEEL LIKE YOU’RE ON A
MOVIE SET, BECAUSE THESE GUYS
USE THE SAME CREW OVER AND OVER
AGAIN, WE’VE BECOME FRIENDS,
THEY’RE REALLY ALL ABOUT THE
CAUSE, THEY’RE AWESOME
PEOPLE, AND THEY’RE USUALLY
WORKING ON MUCH HIGHER LEVEL
PRODUCTIONS, TV SHOWS, MOVIES
THAT KIND OF THING SO THEY
REALLY KNOW WHAT THEY ARE DOING
AND IT’S A FUN THING.
YOU’D BE SURPRISED WE GET IT ALL
DONE WITHIN A DAY, SO IT TAKES
THEM A LONG TIME BUT FOR US IT’S
ACTUALLY NOT THAT MUCH TIME OUT
OF OUR DAY.
>> AND GO AHEAD, JOEY.
YEAH, YOU KNOW, CONGRESSMAN REAL
QUICK I JUST WANT TO SAY I LOVE
YOUR EDGEY ADVERTISING CAMPAIGN
ING I THINK YOU DO A
GREAT JOB REACHING PEOPLE AND
WESLEY AND MORGAN ARE GREAT GUYS
I’VE KNOWN THEM FOREVER BUT I
JUST NEED TO REMIND YOU IT’S NOT
JUST SOCIALISTS THAT SKIP LEG
DAY I NEED TO THROW THAT OUT
THERE I’VE SEEN THE T-SHIRT AND
I APPRECIATE IT, BUT IT’S NOT
JUST THOSE THAT SKIP LEG DAY,
ALL RIGHT?
>> WHO ELSE IS IT?
>> [LAUGHTER]
>> OH, YEAH.
>> CONGRESSMAN, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR JOINING US THIS MORNING
WE APPRECIATE IT.
COVERING A RANGE OF TOPICS.
>> SORRY, I CAN’T SEE YOU GUYS.
>> [LAUGHTER]
>> WE HEAR YOU.